what are the
interesting differences would you say
between um
the various psychedelics that you
mentioned ayahuasca dmt
acid lsd marijuana mescaline pcp cell
cybin mdma
all you mentioned a few of them they're
really interesting we'll we'll talk
about
scientifically some of the the different
studies that have been
conducted on each but sort of at the
high level
what are some interesting differences
well one of the big ones
that people make a big deal of that i
think is completely misplaced
is some are from nature some are from
the lab right so there's this kind of
like romantic thought that if it's from
nature it's good if it's from the lab
it's somehow tainted by humanity
and you know therefore some people are
like all for
plants psychedelics we see the policy
changes that have been happening in a
couple cities uh cambridge
somerville right not far from where
we're at now where they decriminalize
plant medicines so they call it
decriminalizing nature
so i i think that there is
from my perspective certain
certain things from nature are poison
certain things from the lab are
spiritual even if they don't show up in
nature
like lsd now there is something lsd is
lysergic acid diethylamide there is
lysergic acid amide
lsa which comes from morning glory seeds
so it's very similar
but at the same time i'd say i don't buy
into that distinction that there's some
fundamental preference
one of the things that terence mckenna
since we talked about him
he talked about how if it's from nature
it's good and if it's
not you know we should be suspect um
of course he had a lot of great lsd
experiences but actually terrance
in 1984 we were at esalen with a bunch
of other people
this was before the crackdown on mdma
and this was some of the underground
therapists and the above ground
researchers were trying to
talk about how to protect mdma from this
eventual crackdown and
terence was like forget about it you
know it's from the lab
you know it's dangerous we have
thousands of years of history all these
other things and you know what do we
know about mdma and blah blah blah
i was like terence you're so um
unscientific [ __ ] another way to say
it is
and and i just said you know we need a
study of
the safety of mdma and so then dick
price who started um
eslin i said i'll put a thousand dick
prices he'd put a thousand so terence
was actually the catalyst for the first
study with mdma
wow just because he was so frustrating
about how plants are okay
and you know if it's from the lab it's
bad so that's one distinction
the the other distinction is this um
sense of uh classic psychedelics versus
things like mdma so to what extent do
they
dissolve the ego and you could say to
what extent do they
cause visions the 5-ht2a serotonin
receptor subtype
which is responsible for a lot of that
where these drugs are activating
now masculine of all the psychedelics
chemically it's the most similar to mdma
it's a phenethylamine which is mdma so
in the 50s there was the 53 i think it
was the army chemical warfare service
wanted to look at drugs for
interrogations
mind control non-lethal incapacitance
they did
a study in eight substances these were
now toxicity studies in animals
and on the one side was methamphetamine
and the other was mescaline and mdma was
in the middle
chemically so um
masculine of these psychedelics tends to
have the
warmth that mdma has it's not as ego
dissolving quite as some of the others
i mean it's the main active ingredient
in peyote it is very psychedelic very
visual
another distinction with these different
drugs is how long they last
and a lot of that has to do with the
route of administration
so for example if you smoke dmt
it takes 10-15 minutes and you're
within seconds you're off in another
world um similarly 5meodmt
um very rapid when you
take dmt in the form of ayahuasca where
it's mixed with
another substance that makes it so that
it's orally active then it's
a couple hours so
lsd is uh 8 10 12 hours
sometimes psilocybin is more like five
or six hours or
four to six hours mdma is similar
it's one reason why in our research we
give
an initial dose of mdma and then two
hours later we give half the initial
amount
to extend the plateau because we want it
to last longer
for people to be in this therapeutic
state
so that's another distinction is you
know how long these drugs last
another distinction is which of them
come from
a religious context have a religion
built around them
we have this um sense that some people
are saying that 5meo dmt
and the sonoran toad that they have this
long history of indigenous use but they
don't that's all modern it's made up
and it's kind of a new approach however
there was thousands of years of use of
psilocybin mushrooms in religious
contexts
um from um 1600
bc to 396 a.d the world's
longest mystery ceremonies the
eleusinian mysteries
you know sort of the heart of greek
culture the heart of western culture
that was a psychedelic potion called
kikion
that seems like it's very much like an
lsd-like substance
air got on grain and
you know lsd comes from aragon
so i think that there are a lot of ways
to look at these different substances
another
distinction is um you know which one of
them
are being researched right now in
scientific context and which are not
um and because of the rise of all these
for-profit companies and everybody's
looking for what they can patent what
they can claim the land grab
you know more and more there are
companies looking at every different
kind of psychedelics
the ones that are most important that
are not being researched
mescaline but now there's a company to
do mescaline a journey collab
i ibogaine which is crucial for opiate
addiction
there's a new company a
branch of this company a thai that's
going to be looking at ibogaine
so i'd say the rise of the for-profit
companies is making it so that
um there's just going to be an enormous
amount of investigations
into all these different psychedelics
but what we're going to see is the
development of new psychedelics that we
don't know anything about
that have not existed yet because a lot
of these for-profit companies
are going to want to invent and patent
and have
composition of matter patents on new
molecules
so i think we'll see a lot of that
happening too
you